I've asked this question myself when I
was a kid but you you brought it up
already three times now so why don't we
start there why are some people rich and
some people poor according to you well
because our systems our economic systems
are set up like that there is no way
that a capitalist system of the sort we
have could have any other outcome than
to make a minority rich and a majority
poor I mean it's a little bit like sort
of understanding the the history of
economic systems the major three
economic systems over the last several
thousand years at least I'm talking now
you know Western Europe North America
and so on the major three were slavery
feudalism and then capitalism and
there's something all three of them have
in common a small number of people said
at the top of this society in slavery
it's the master and feudalism it's the
Lord and in capitalism it's the employer
and a vast majority of people are in the
other position they're the serf or the
slave or the employee and it shouldn't
surprise you that if you look at slavery
the Masters are rich and powerful and
the slaves and large are not and if you
look at feudalism the Lords are rich and
powerful and by and large the serfs are
not and we live in a capitalist system
where by and large the employers do
really well relatively and the employees
well I'll be nice not so much and in
order for us not to have this split
between rich and poor whether it's on
the level of a region or a nation or
inside a small community we would have
to confront whether the effort to
overcome the better the gap between rich
and poor is a reasonable objective if
you abstract from the economic system
that basically produces those things
that's why I said at the beginning when
you asked me the question I hate rich
people no I know they end up like people
me who come from modest circumstances
very hard not to conclude as you go
through life okay I see now that there
are rich people and poor people and it
isn't hard for me to tell you which I'd
rather be I'd rather be there than over
there but the problem is there aren't
enough there's for everybody who feels
that way to get to that point and it's a
very sad reality that is hard for people
to come to terms with which is why
people like aim Rand can be popular
because she presents an idea that
suggests oh we could all do this and you
don't believe that not for one my gosh
Richard come on
[Music]